you hosted start out live as I mentioned
brilliantly last weekend you're very
nice job and you know what I like was
nice is you gave your kids a shout out
at the at the end of the show I mean the
model the model in the monologue I gave
my kids a shout out yeah well cuz what
happened was the monologue of the show
during dress rehearsal was something
totally different or not totally
different but it was it was all kind of
different jokes and stuff and then and
he was that thing before air where you
know the audience is being led in for
the air show and Lauren's like do we
want to do that more Michael's like
maybe we don't do that monologue we do
something else and and John Mulaney was
there and John Mulaney was like well
yeah it could be this or that and I'm
like we have to make a decision you know
so I'm flipping out so they wrote new
jokes and then I go there's no ending
and Loren said well when in doubt you
know say hi to your kids say hi to your
kids and I like to other people do that
on the show is that just a thing right
do you in Canada but but yeah so I said
hi to my kids and but and then I told
them I you know I call me hey guys did
you see daddy on the show I said hi to
you and they're like yeah yeah we saw
that I go did you did you like the show
and they go all you did was laugh I know
I know they're like that's how you make
money you just go on TV and just laugh
at yourself yeah that's why you're going
to private school you little beaver
you you did eight seasons I'm out live
and this is your second time hosting
right yes it your second time hosting
but you still got nervous for the
monologue which I can totally believe
because all the when I were to turn it
live the monologue was the last thing
that came together that's every single
week and you would at least know better
yeah but most guests would be like when
do we do that work out the monologue and
all week long they just hear you just
kick it down yeah they just feel like oh
it's all being taken care of and it's
not yeah there's whole meetings if
anybody's gonna host that's no just you
know when they go we're taking care of
the monologue that means they're not
taking care of the monologue and there's
a whole room or they go okay cool and
then go on the go yeah and I just want
to thank my kids people thinking kids
that they don't have yeah yeah the kids
I hope to have someday with someone
gorgeous yeah I don't know it was weird
but it is it is like I really just just
them saying your name and you run out
there and everyone is screaming and
stuff and you just kind of go like yeah
it's terrifying
so John Mulaney new hero at the
monologue and he knew I'd be nervous so
he just had me say I'm nervous
it was nice that was nice and I love him
yeah yeah hi John yeah I wanna go he's
never gonna see this
not a fan of the show
you